if they've got their own guys that's
that's great Jackson they've got their
own people and but you know there's
plenty of people on the roster that have
an MMA coach and a grappling coach and
that's it so the performances that you
we feel we can help and support those
guys you bridge the gap right and we're
not trying to displace the the programs
where athletes already have resources
but I don't know of another MMA gym
globally that has the capacity around
assessment that we do so yeah we have we
have some really great practitioners but
Bo San of our strength coach and his
team cannot write programs for 570
athletes it's not possible but what we
can do is assess those athletes provide
that feedback back to their strength
coaches and have conversations about how
those coaches can use that data to
support the development of that athlete
and that that goes across the board for
all of our performance services well
it's a pretty amazing resource because
if you're a young fighter and all you
have is access to the people around you
you if you're fighting in the UFC you
get to have access like instantaneously
to this gigantic group of people or it's
like it went for us when you were coming
up you mean you were real pioneer I mean
that was that was not available to a guy
like you know I mean I told the story
all the time but so I was actually a
little bit ahead of my time I had you
know I had an actual strength coach that
had letters behind his name I went to
college to be a strength coach not there
was like an ex bodybuilder I had you
know a relatively good nutrition as to
at least had a degree in chemical
biology I had a good physical therapist
but I didn't really have like I was my
coach you know at the end of the day I
was the head of performance so I'd go
did you Jitsu and you know jiu-jitsu
coach one should go hard and then you go
kickbox but you're gonna go light but
it's kick butt so you don't and then you
know and now you know nobody's to the
strength coach and nutritionists
throwing different pages so I think just
understanding that everything has to
work together which I didn't really
understand well what I'm saying is that
you kind of had to pave a path because
when a guy like you was doing all that
stuff with a real legitimate strengthen
condition coach real legitimate
nutritionist how many other people were
doing that at your time not that many
but I got to be around good people like
Randy Couture Chuck Liddell those were
kind of guys I got to hang out
and say well he does this he does that
Chuck actually what him didn't have much
of this stuff but Randy was right I know
what I'm doing Kate all right yes sir
yeah he just existed on pure savagery
when you step back and look at your
career like how amazing is it to be able
to step off from there and do something
like you're doing now for the UFC
Performance Institute it was just very
meaningful for young fighters I mean you
really do get a chance to give back with
your experience and your understanding
of the right way in the wrong way the
mistakes that you've made it's huge I
mean that's the whole thing I mean
that's a whole genesis kind of from from
my involvement in the I like to look
here's the ten thousand mistakes I made
yeah you're gonna make mistakes too but
these are the ones you don't need to
make you know again the sports changed
man it's 25 years old
every other sports so evolved bends
around so long our sport changes all the
time I forget who was talking about it
but you know even the guys fighting ten
years ago probably couldn't compete with
gas fighting today you know but I mean
what I would say as well and it's not
only for the fighters forest is a huge
resource for us the bet the best piece
of technology we have is the door handle
that leads from my office to forest
office right because ultimately he's a
massive resource for us that are not
necessarily coming from an MMA
background and are trying to support the
MMA community to bounce ideas off to
essentially beta-test things from a
thought process perspective and he's a
huge part of the performance institute
philosophy because we can use and call
upon his expertise so here's another
funny thing when we were putting
together the the the team for the PI I
kind of shied away from people already
doing MMA I wanted combat sports
everybody that's done it has done judo
boxing on an Olympic level they've done
combat sports but I wanted like a fresh
set of eyes coming from a different you
know then just you know because I know
really good and I'm a strength coaches I
know pretty good
MMA you know you you you know good and
but get get that fresh set of eyes you
know nutrition actually was a little
different because the rest of the world
does not understand a way cut for an MMA
fight it's not like it you know we go to
exos you go to any high level facility
and they you say I'm gonna lose Apes
my body weight and then compete on
Saturday they're like now don't just
fight in the highway class I'm like yeah
that actually isn't gonna work out for
me they they just won't comprehend it
though I know you'll perform better like
matter